infos du jour il y a ces déclarations
d'un ami Jacques cardoz qui est autour
de la table c'est lui ce qui ne le
connaissent pas
c'est lui il a donné une interview
Figaro on le rappelle avant de rejoindre
Jacques présenter l'émission Complément
d'enquête sur France 2 On n'a jamais
parlé autant de cette émission
et c'est déclarations font énormément de
bruit puisqu'il a révélé qu'il a été
interdit d'enquêter sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon parachille Verdez non je
rigole mais bon ça aurait pu regarder ça
c'est fou quand j'ai vu ça nous avait
parlé mais là
quand même regarde c'est parti sur 50
émissions il y en a une qui s'attaque à
une personnalité de gauche à l'époque je
voulais faire une enquête sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon on me l'a refusait c'était
quand même pile-poil au moment où il
avait dit la République c'est moi il y
avait largement de quoi faire un
complément d'enquête on me l'a refusait
et on a eu même ce mot qui m'a quand
même alors là je suis tombé de l'armoire
où on m'a dit non mais tu comprends la
France insoumise nous donne tellement de
dossiers qu'on peut pas travailler et on
peut pas travailler contre c'est
incroyable alors 53 on est en direct
c'est quoi cette histoire tu voulais
faire un truc à l'époque où il y a eu la
perquisition je voulais faire un 52 sur
sur Mélenchon pour qu'on pour qu'on ait
vraiment
qu'on puisse vraiment analyser le
personnage ses contradictions le mettre
en face de ses propres contradictions
comme on l'a fait sur sur d'autres
personnalités sur Carlos Ghosn sur du
pont Moretti sur fin sur plein de monde
et ben oui c'est pas un secret de dire
que au sein de complément d'enquête on a
plutôt un penchant pour taper sur la
droite que pour taper sur la gauche donc
moi je me souviendrai toujours de ce que
m'a dit Hervé Brusini c'est le patron du
Prix Albert Londres le prix Albert
Londres c'est le prix le summum en
matière d'investigation le Graal il
m'avait dit si tu veux être respecté
faut être redouté et pour être redouté
il faut que tu tapes aussi bien d'un
côté que de l'autre parce que il faut
jamais que les gens puissent deviner
pour qui tu votes et il faut jamais donc
voilà donc et l'autre l'autre chose
c'est que lorsque je suis arrivé à la
tête de complément la direction qui en
était pleinement consciente m'avait dit
on compte sur toi pour les tenir parce
qu'il y avait eu des mouvements les dans
les mois qui ont précédé il y avait eu
etc et donc on m'avait dit voilà on
compte sur toi aussi pour faire en sorte
que ce soit équilibré parce qu'une
émission d'investigation comme celle-là
elle est magnifique avec des gens qui
travaillent très bien ça n'est pas le
problème c'est que on doit faire en
sorte d'être neutre c'est pas possible
mais de donner un équilibre et
l'équilibre consiste à taper aussi bien
d'un côté que de l'autre j'ai été choqué
comme ça et j'ai également été choqué
qu'on me traite de facho parce que je
voulais faire une enquête sur
l'islamo-gauchisme on l'a fait mais ça a
été ça a été compliqué il y a plusieurs
journalistes qui leur faisaient avant
qu'un troisième qu'une troisième
finalement l'accepte et sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon comment tu as dit non tu as
été quand en fait si tu veux complément
d'enquête c'est une émission ou le
patron et le rédacteur en chef le
présentateur et le rédacteur en chef un
pulse mais c'est impossible de faire une
enquête si la totalité des journalistes
sont contre il y a une dizaine de
reporters et la plupart des reporters ne
voulaient pas freiner des cas de fer et
j'ai vu le communiqué de SDJ il y a
quelques jours qui disait mais non
complément est une émission très
équilibrée et ils ont cité un certain
nombre de thèmes et en réalité des
thèmes de gauche il y en a que deux il y
a eu en 50 émissions c'est depuis que je
suis pareil il y a eu une émission sur
Anne Hidalgo et une sur Sandrine
Rousseau et un Hidalgo c'est moi qui
l'avais commandé mais comme il faut 6
mois ou un an pour que les sujets se
fassent voilà donc en fait il y en a eu
qu'une moi j'ai eu le sentiment la
dernière année ma dernière année d'être
un peu dépossédé et j'ai eu le sentiment
de pas pouvoir exactement faire ce que
je voulais faire et je trouve dommage
parce que la règle du service public le
service public n'est comparable à
personne le service public ça doit être
la neutralité ça doit être l'exemple
parce que tous les gens qui sont ici ils
donnent 150 euros par an donc et cet
argent public là
le service public doit être redevable de
ça et une émission d'investigation elle
doit être au dessus de tout Guillaume
non mais là cette émission n'a plus
aucune crédibilité elle prend clairement
les téléspectateurs pour des cons c'est
qu'on est sur une émission qui est censé
être de service public qui est censé
impartial qui est censés parler de ce
qui concerne la France de ce qui fait
l'actualité et on se rend compte qu'en
coulisse il y a des magouilles on refuse
des sujets on en fait d'autres qui sont
des sujets commandés c'est n'importe
quoi on prend les gens pour des cons
c'est comme nous ici on peut refuser des
il y a des sujets mais je comprends pas
là c'est le service public directement
et pardon mais au moment de la
République c'est moi Jean-Luc Mélenchon
aurait mérité une enquête est-ce que
vous vous méritez une enquête maintenant
qu'il y a déjà eu une enquête il y a pas
une enquête mais Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'était une affaire publique là on voit
que c'est complètement gratos et ça
décrédibilise des missions c'est pas
digne du service public pourquoi
pourquoi ils ont refusé changement avec
Mélenchon clairement l'une des
journalistes m'avait dit non on peut pas
faire ça parce que parce que la France
insoumise c'est eux qui nous donne des
dossiers des dossiers sur des fermetures
d'usine des dossiers sur c'est vrai
qu'ils sont très actifs et que dans la
mesure où complément est une émission
qui revisite beaucoup les fermetures
d'usine les problèmes d'emploi
bah du coup tu as besoin des tu as
besoin d'avoir des sources et la France
insoumise fait partie des partis
politiques qui donnent les dossiers ou
sur des sujets la France insoumise par
exemple on va faire ça il faudrait faire
ça il faudrait faire ci là bah oui parce
que il y a une forme de connivence et
d'amitié etc encore une fois moi que mes
anciens camarades ne se trompent pas je
suis pas en train de dire que c'est pas
une bonne émission c'est pas le problème
ou qui travaille mal je dis que
lorsqu'on fait une émission comme
celle-là et qu'on a 50 sujets sur deux
ans le minimum c'est quand même que on
tape autant d'un côté que de l'autre et
que ce soit pas tout le temps contre les
riches contre les patrons contre la
police c'est mal contre voilà et non il
se passe aussi beaucoup de choses à
raconter j'ai envie de dire de l'autre
côté voilà c'est ce que je pense oui non
mais j'entends parfaitement ce que dit
Jacques puis il a vécu donc c'est vrai
mais est-ce que votre enquête sur
Mélenchon elle aurait pas été à charge
vous dites vous dire vous dites vous
vouliez bah non pas peu importe ce qu'on
dénonce c'est ce qu'on dénonce sur
d'autres voitures du moment où il y a
une enquête à complément c'est à charge
vous dites que vous dire vous dites que
vous voulez enquêter sur l'islamo
gauchisme par exemple voilà votre but
c'était de prouver que sacrifie
recrutent des personnes arabo-musulmanes
c'est ce que vous avez dit en banlieue
le vote musulman il est acqué à 70% à
LFI alors j'avais quoi le but de l'encre
mes amis je vais te répondre très
précisément Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est
quelque chose qui est totalement reconnu
du côté de ça soumise a fait l'analyse à
la dernière présidentielle que il lui
manquait 700 à 800000 voix et que c'est
700 800000 voix il pouvait aller les
chercher en sa coquinant avec une
certaine frange de la population c'est
déjà un jugement de valeur parce que
c'est en fait lorsque tu regardes cette
enquête regarde cette enquête et on n'a
pas été les premiers à l'affaire regarde
cette enquête tu verras que en effet il
y a une relation et une collusion entre
entre certaines cautions de banlieue qui
peuvent apporter un vote à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui n'a pas toujours été sur
cette ligne politique voilà vous avez un
truc
mon enquête quand ils font une enquête
c'est toujours un chat
et j'adore non mais Cyril moi j'adore ça
en fait toute la question est de savoir
s'ils vont trouver des choses qui sont
suffisamment croustillantes si à un
moment donné il trouve pas suffisamment
de choses croustillantes sur toi et ben
au fil du temps il finiront par dire non
mais on a voulu faire un portrait assez
équilibré et donc forcément il y aura
plus de gens qui parleront bien de toi
que de ce que dans les gens
ils appellent pas trop ah bah oui mais
s'il trouve rien ils l'ont annoncé ce
complément donc il va falloir le faire
il faut faire les 52 minutes je t'avais
déjà expliqué que je suis 52 minutes et
oui mais je t'avais déjà expliqué que
moi j'étais aussi contre les les 52
minutes parce que je pense qu'un 52 ça
pousse à essayer de faire de de mettre
de charger la barque de mettre
énormément de choses alors que tous les
sujets ne méritent pas 52 minutes
parfois c'est 15 c'est 20 et l'idée
originale de Benoît Duquesne le créateur
de cette émission qui est
malheureusement disparu et qui est
décédé oui c'était
quatre trois ou quatre trois ou quatre
sujets dans une même soirée qui se
contredisent et avec voilà de la
contradiction et
ils estimait que le Mélenchon t'as pas
pu le faire dans le complément d'enquête
parce qu'il avait déjà été fait dans
envoyer spécialiste merci de poser la
question il y a eu plein de fois où
envoyer a fait un sujet complément la
fête 3 mois après et quand les
journalistes de complément d'enquête
veulent vraiment faire quelque chose
crois-moi qu'il le font et la direction
elle a rien à dire c'est tu sais fut un
temps on disait à complément lorsque je
suis arrivé à complément la direction de
l'info m'a dit c'est une secte donc il
va falloir que tu te fasses accepter et
il va falloir que en même temps je les
adore je veux dire c'est des très bons
journalistes et que qu'on se méprenne
pas sur ce que je dis mais faire du
travail un très bon travail mais
toujours le faire dans une même
direction ça n'est pas le rôle du
service public le service public n'a pas
à être politisé quand tu prends un
groupe privé ou un journal privé tu sais
à qui il appartient chacun se fait son
opinion le service public doit être
exemplaire je pense qu'il y a une dérive
et on leur racontera dans en cas de
vraiment exactement en début d'année
prochaine je pense qu'il y a une dérive
et tout sera vérifiable et les gens il y
aura du contradictoire les gens pourront
venir et et et nous contredire si on se
trompe et si je me mets chaque juste une
petite précision parce que j'ai pas très
bien compris vous dites que donc en gros
il y avait des sortes de de pression
c'était un peu gangrené la rédaction de
complément d'enquête par les lanceurs
d'alerte lfist mais est-ce que en haut
de France Télévisions ils le savent ça
est-ce que la direction de France
Télévisions la conscience de ça alors
oui parce que moi j'avais des échanges
avec la direction et c'est normal le
présentateur est responsable de de
l'émission et j'avais des échanges en
permanence avec ma direction donc il y
avait franchement une grande
transparence à ce niveau là mais la
direction de France c'est que ça se
passe mais en fait et ça pour le coup je
leur donne raison la direction peut pas
à un moment donné mettre les mains dans
une émission comme celle-là parce que ça
veut dire qu'il y a intervention et
honnêtement pendant trois ans il y a
jamais eu d'intervention ils ont été
hyper clean avec moi la seule émission
qui a été une émission à même ça a été
une émission sur la télé où j'ai pas pu
faire ce que je voulais puisqu'on m'a
décommandé c'est sur quoi c'était
c'était sur c'était au moment de du
mouvement des gilets jaunes il y avait
un sujet sur les journalistes de rue il
y avait il y avait il y avait on était
on a été les premiers à faire un sujet
sur les dips sur le Deep fake on avait
été on avait été ça avait été le premier
sujet par un très bon joueur qui
s'appelle Milano Dupont mais surtout je
voulais avoir deux journalistes en en
plateau dans les fauteuils et on m'a
décommandé monsieur veille qui était
patron de BFM
quelques jours avant donc là il y a eu
une intervention très claire et puis on
m'a décommandé aussi la journaliste de
France Inter spécialiste des médias dont
j'ai oublié le nom là mais vous allez
bien voilà et parce que je voulais que
français je les écoute pas mais je les
connais elle avait dit des choses
désagréables contre France Télé quelques
semaines avant et on me l'avait
décommandé alors que au contraire je
voulais faire elle est très bien et
surtout je voulais faire une émission
sur la télé à condition que il y ait une
forme d'autocritique contre France Télé
bien sûr et cette autocritique elle est
voilà elle était pas complètement là
c'est compliqué allez on va se retrouver
dans un instant